ضربه صاروخيه قويه تعرضت لها مدينه
كريفيري الواقعه جنوب مقاطعه
دينابروبيتروسك الجنوبيه اوكرانيا هذه
الضربه خلفت اثارا كبيره واضرارا ماديه
بالاضافه الى خسائر بشريه كبيره نشاهد حجم
الدمار في هذه المدينه التي تعتبر مسقط
راس الرئيس الاوكراني
قد زارها قبل ايام نشاهد اعمال الاغاثه
التي ما زالت مستمره
لانقاذ مفقودين تحت الانقاض في هذه
الاثناء يتم العمل على البحث عن مفقودين
يجري الحديث عن خمسه مفقودين على الاقل
بالاضافه الى سته قتلى وفق المعطيات
الاوليه اضافه الى 25
جريحا سقطوا في هذا
التفجير وهذه الضربه الصاروخيه التي تعرضت
لها المدينه وهي واحده من بين ضربات اخرى
ايضا تعرضت لها هذه المنطقه
فجره اليوم اثار الدمار كبيره للغايه في
هذا الموقع ونشاهد كيف ان
ايضا المكان ما زال يحتضن جثث للضحايا في
هذا المكان الذي تخفيه ايضا
القوات الامنيه هنا جراء هذه الضربه
الصاروخيه التي تعتبر من بين الضربات
الاكبر التي تعرضت لها مدينه هذه الضربه
تاتي في ظل ايضا ضربات مدفعيه صاروخيه على
عدد من المناطق التي تحيط بالمنطقه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه حيث تجري العمليات
العسكريه ويجري الحديث عن عمليات الهجوم
المضاده الاوكراني حسن مسعود الجزيره
كريفيري